hey and welcome back to a series of
which I haven't uploaded that video in a
little bit too long more about that
later but basically this video will be
mostly about laying down a new town and
the area around it though I won't go
entirely into detail and really keep it
just do the planning in this episode and
go to more of the detailing in the next
episode slash episodes but yeah there is
something that I should probably talk
about which is the fact that it's like
taking me a week since the last video
over a week to upload this one and
basically it has to do with the issue
that I'm currently having where lately
I've been sort of busy so I can't really
make too many videos but now that I've
picked it up again and I am recording
many videos in the game I can't quite
keep up with actually recording
commentaries for the videos and
producing the videos themselves so I'm
sort of getting behind in that aspect
so while I'm talking I'm actually
already at episode 19 which is terribly
far ahead but yeah something to keep in
mind is that it'll take me like extra
long in this time to get back to
feedback so yeah that's something that
even though I am quite happy to take any
feedback about this area that I can
especially since I haven't gotten still
haven't gotten too much experience with
how I should lay this down and really
got it mostly from suggestions and a lot
of looking at Google Maps and Wikipedia
pages and things like that there's still
a lot that I can improve about this but
keep in mind that when I do so I'll do
so in an episode quite far ahead in the
future anyway over here I wanted to have
a small industrial area it's not quite
very large this one of those sort of
outer industrial retail business ish
areas with there's a bit of mixed zoning
in here as well so there's a few offices
distribution center in some industry as
well but generally one of those more
industrial areas outside the city but
it's not entirely a very large area I
want to keep most of the industrial
places around the harbour which I'm
planning to have in the future so this
is more or less just a sort of new
development that might always grow in
the future just outside the city which I
wanted to have here
and then this national highway sort of
thing with the dirt around it is going
to be the main road which is going to
lead to the new town which I want to
have around here and also start laying
down in this episode and it'll really
just go through this countryside which
or just be grassy fields with
windbreakers and a few farms something
to keep in mind at this point in time is
that I do think right here I am made the
fields a little bit too small and I also
had too many farms considering how small
the fields of the farms are so I'm
already going to change that in future
episodes that is definitely something
I'll get to and but yeah there should be
the overall layout of this area as well
be in the end and the general idea of
how I'm laying this down because the
thing is you can't exactly talk about
one type of rural landscape let alone
one type of country scientist in the
Netherlands so this is very much based
on the South of South Holland but also
sort of the northwest of brow bones
which is very much a style which is
somewhat old so there are some of these
very much longer medieval fields but
also some dikes that sort of go through
everywhere and as a general theme the
way it's sort of laid out is to have
these curvy roads and little rivers go
through the landscape first and then
sort of try the grid the areas that are
left between that's and actually find
that also a very good way to try to get
a as natural and organic as possible
looking layout of the fields as you can
without having to go to completely
random types of shapes so really the
idea is to lay down these sort of curvy
roads first they're very old and weren't
planned at all but what I'm trying to at
least somewhat account for is this sort
of historical aspect that you will find
this sort of legacy effect of the old
roads that just go randomly everywhere
and have curves and just aren't so great
and these fields that are very long and
sort of remnants of even medieval times
as well but
than over time you also add these more
great like roads in between them and
what happens quite a lot actually as
well is that different farmers sort of
exchange fields or change their fields
shapes over time to be more efficient
and that's something which I try to sort
of account in this way too so really as
a general measure it's just lay down
random curvy roads just about everywhere
and try to actually get some organized
looking fields in between that now when
it comes to this town over here it's
kind of mid-sized town I took some
inspiration for it's from cities
especially a city called Devon which is
somewhere in the eastern part of the
country and there are many small towns
like this though it's amazing it's
basically very much centered around the
railroad so it has an almost circular
type shape around the railroad and
nothing special really there and
consists just out of an old part of the
town with some 60s 70s row houses and a
few more modern developments but no real
v-necks
ish developments as you would see around
larger cities so this is really going to
still be a quite a small town and I want
to keep this as more of a historical
cute ish town then I went then as a
large city so that's really the idea
behind this it's not especially designed
or planned area to be near the big city
but just sort of a small town that
supposedly sort of organically grew over
time and that's really a major
inspiration for it a bit of inspiration
you can find in a city called Houghton
as well especially with having that sort
of ring-road around it which is
obviously added in a much later stage of
this town with all the roundabouts which
sort of connect the roads to where you
can actually enter the city and though I
didn't expect it prior to making this I
really did need them and this is really
one issue which sort of constraints in
the game and I wouldn't want to see
realistically it's the fact that you get
unholy amounts of traffic in this game
like really a town like this should
realistically get just a bit of traffic
but I think in the game they're not 100%
sure about this
Villages goes to work and works for five
minutes and returns and because of this
sort of time not really working in a
realistic way even if you have rush
hours
the days are obviously much shorter
there's a lot more traffic just
something which I think is the cons in
any case there is a lot more traffic
than there should realistically be so I
will get some minor issues with traffic
in the future with this town especially
the highway that leads to it but in
general it sort of works pretty well I'm
actually really happy I got those
roundabouts over there in the end
because within the town there shouldn't
be any congestion problems at any point
so yeah this is really the old center of
the town as you can also see you in the
very curvy or not curvy but very random
sort of roads that go into all
directions and aren't really planned at
all but just sort of shaped that way of
course there's one Road which goes
straight alongside the rail and there's
one sort of Center Road which meets up
with that parallel but around that I
really wanted to have some roads with
which one just about everywhere and then
to the right of that old centre with the
church I wanted to add the sort of pre
slash post-world War row houses the very
typically touch row houses with the red
roofs and all the brick walls and really
in a quite classical way just wanted to
get them in a very straight grid-like
pattern for a bit over there and then to
the left of that area I wanted to have
the 70s ish neighbourhood which is
almost like a cauliflower neighbourhood
but not quite and of course it's a lot
smaller but it really still follows the
same ideas with the curvy roads and all
of the little pedestrian shortcuts
between everything and you'll see that
return in the types of houses that I'll
be using in that area as well and the
same really goes for what's above the
railroad I want to sort of follow a same
layouts as I do underneath it and really
have some of the oldest houses in the
town or at least the top part of the
town just around the railroad and have
some detached houses as well and have
some slightly newer developments
just outside and near the border of the
town and something that I really wanted
to keep in mind in this case is that
since it's such a small town the
different areas or different parts of it
shouldn't feel like they're separate
neighborhoods and really even though
they're you can definitely tell that
different parts should be somewhat older
and somewhat newer parts and they have
different types of layouts and different
house types all of the developments
aren't quite large and generally that is
something I do like to think about is
that if you have such a small town then
unless it's going to be some sort of
suburb office of a surrounding large
city it really grows quite organically
in a way that it still grows quite
planned but really in very small steps
at a time so wanted to avoid adding any
type of really large neighbourhood
that's really focused on its own but
every sort of addition to the town
should still keep the town as a whole if
that makes any sense I wanted to make
sure that every addition really wouldn't
turn inward too much I'm gonna have
their own thing but it would still keep
the overall shape of the town going and
keep it as a whole and not separated too
much same sort of goes for the railroad
actually since there is obviously a
railroad running straight through a town
it's sort of a problem because you can
have that effect where it really breaks
up the town if you like you have two
halves that are completely detached from
each other and just don't have much to
do with each other and all and that's
why I really wanted to make sure I had
those three different places where the
road goes underneath the railroad and
also there is a pedestrian bridge as
well at the station only thing I should
note about this station is that while
I've gone with a certain station and
you'll see this at some point in the
future I've went with a certain station
but didn't realize that actually this
station doesn't have a tunnel or a
bridge to get to the other side of the
rail so while I added that pedestrian
bridge myself the station doesn't
functionally use it so like the people
in the station naturally just spawn on
the other side of the room which is very
awkward and I might replace the station
it's a point in future but yeah it's
something to keep in mind
the moment that yeah my people are
behaving in strange ways in the station
but that's completely normal at or at
least it's supposed to happen I can't do
much about it until I get a different
station at some point in the future
anyway this is yeah this is really that
type of 80s yeah I would actually say
80s it's a little less random and bit
more complex shapes here and there then
you would see in very typical
cauliflower neighborhoods but it still
sort of has that cauliflower ish style
to it and definitely some of the
different housing styles as well the
only thing that I really sort of made a
mistake of when it comes to this area is
that all of the little areas where I
didn't own anything and when I had those
pedestrian paths sort of make the little
plazas are going to be playgrounds in
the future and while it's realistic to
have a good amount of playgrounds around
your houses in the Netherlands I went
way overboard with this so might also
want to change that in the future even
if just a little bit but yeah this is by
far the largest new sort of developments
in this town the idea is that this
entire development sort of happened
simultaneously with the little centre
area there with the supermarket and also
the school which you can see at the top
which is just hidden underneath chirpy I
think that's it's not yeah but yeah the
idea is that this is sort of a new
neighbourhood has a very large expansion
of the town where at the time when this
was built quite obviously really doubled
the town in size but that all of this
was planned and built at the same time
so that's why this is very much in the
same style and really goes along with
the centre of the town as well and style
but I also wanted to use this as a way
to make sure that in the heart of the
town which is around that runabout which
has the supermarket's and the high
school you sort of have that sort of
central little place in the town where
you have the most important services I
totally have a Town Hall you would
commonly see that as well but yeah and
sounds like these where you just have a
couple thousand inhabitants
you do quite often see that in the
middle of the town there is this sort of
slightly newer place with newer
buildings where they have like the City
Hall and if they have a high school
their high school or otherwise some
elementary school and some supermarkets
it's really that type of area which I
wanted to have in the middle there and
this is also what I meant with the new
neighbourhood not going to turn inward
too much because even though it's sort
of part of those new developments the
centre with the supermarket really is at
the side of this newer neighborhood it
sort of connects it with the rest of the
town so I really wanted to not put the
heart of this new part of the town in
the middle of this new part since
obviously then you would sort of get two
cores of the town and sort of detach
them from each other and really wanted
to make sure that whatever was in the
centre of the city would really be sort
of the heart so yeah it was basically an
attempt to make sure that this newer
area even though it's much newer than
the old core of the town really goes
along with the old core core and doesn't
feel like it's completely apart from it
though then again I didn't put
everything in that part in the middle of
the town since actually have the high
school and the small Hospital as well
here on the side which was really just
because of space convenience I couldn't
really manage to get that in anywhere
else and really figured well if anything
is gonna have to do the side would be
pretty okay especially since you don't
quite need to go to the hospital as
often as you need to go to the
supermarket or at least hopefully that
is at least that goes for most people
but yeah that's the overall idea of this
town I'll get into the details later on
so definitely don't want to do the
foliage quite yet and you'll see that in
the next episode and I'll also start
spamming playgrounds at that point but
in general yeah this is going to be the
finished layer it's not really adding
anything beside from what you're seeing
right now really want to keep it this
small and more of just you know I want
to try out different things within this
map and sort of make a Dutch province so
I didn't want to relate everything back
to the original large city that I have
so this is really
a town which supposedly stands on its
own and doesn't have anything to do with
the large city aside just being pretty
close to it anyway that's it for this
episode so thank you guys for watching
and hasta LaVista